tout un travail qui a été fait pendant
des années tu seras jamais dévoilé
devant un tribunal parce qu'on s'est
enfergé dans des techniques qualités
c'est ça la réalité actuelle
[Musique]
depuis 10 ans chaque fois que lui Pâques
débarque quelque part ça fait les
manchettes mais la réalité c'est que bon
nombre de ses enquêtes se sont enlisées
dans des débats judiciaires
interminables devant des tribunaux
complètement engorgés dans une rare
entrevue le commissaire de l'IPAC
Frédéric Gaudreault dit que ça ne peut
plus continuer bonjour Monsieur le
Commissaire Gaudreault en ce moment on
parle beaucoup dans les médias de la
crise qui secoue les tribunaux vous
aussi vous avez des enjeux importants
pour vous en ce moment
fait les manchettes notamment sur la
question de nos délais au niveau de nos
enquêtes
lorsqu'on fait une perquisition les gens
s'attendent à un résultat dans les
semaines qui suivent on n'est pas dans
un lieu où on a trouvé des armes à feu
où il y a de la drogue sur la table on
est dans un lieu où il y a de la
documentation qui contient
potentiellement des preuves qui
pourraient déterminer si un infraction
criminelle ou quoi qui était commune la
corruption pour moi elle est extrêmement
préoccupante mais on peut pas arriver
avec des résultats aussi rapide puisque
dans la plupart de nos dossiers après
perquisition il y a une revendication
d'un secret professionnel donc il y a
évidemment un principe fondamental dans
la justice au Canada qui est le droit au
secret lorsqu'on discute avec un avocat
lorsqu'on veut avoir accès par exemple à
du matériel qu'on a perquisitionné se
dit secret professionnel là nous empêche
d'avoir accès au contenu des
perquisitions qu'on a fait donc c'est là
que ça se complique ça sérieusement
ralenti votre travail dans les dernières
années cette invocation du secret
professionnel de l'avocat tout à fait en
fait il y a sans entrer dans un arrêt de
la course suprême qui date de 2002 avec
laquelle on se gouverne dans le cadre de
ces perquisitions là mais le problème
c'est que dans 2002 c'est un document
dans une filière aujourd'hui les
municipalités gèrent leur information
sur des serveurs informatiques dans une
perquisition maintenant un terrain acté
de donner c'est plus rare on envoie
régulièrement juste pour vous donner un
exemple un image ça représente
6.5 millions de documents papier c'est
comme 1300 classeurs
et là nous il faut aller chercher ce qui
nous intéresse plus il y a de matériel
plus la question du secret professionnel
risque d'être invoquée plus ça risque de
créer des débats donc des délais on peut
pas voir évidemment le matériel jusqu'à
ce que le tribunal ou en fait une
entente en tes différentes parties
permettent à un tiers qui est un ami de
la cour de regarder le matériel et nous
dire dorénavant c'est correct il y a pas
de privilège à blanc vous allez pouvoir
le regarder mais cette période là de
temps que ça prend en ce moment où on a
fait notre perquisition et le moment où
on peut avoir accès au fameux documents
c'est extrêmement long c'est comme étant
moyenne on a fait l'exercice parce que
moi ça me préoccupait comme gestionnaire
qui dit mais pourquoi nos enquêtes sont
si donc pour se faire projet que nos
enquêtes sont longues du faites moi donc
sortir les dossiers dans lequel on a eu
des privilèges qui ont été demandé on
est arrivé avec les moyens de 1000 jours
entre le moment de la perquisition et le
moment où l'enquêteur peut commencer à
regarder le document ce qui est deux ans
et 9 mois diriez-vous on est dans un
moment actuellement où il y a quelque
chose qui va casser moi je suis très
préoccupé par le nombre de requêtes
parfois on se demande si on va capable
de se rendre jusqu'au bout du processus
judiciaire parce que il y aura justement
des techniques qui seront relevées qui
nous empêcheront de déposer notre preuve
tout le monde a entendu parler de vos
perquisitions dans les entreprises liées
à Marc Bibeau on rappelle que pas
d'accusation dans ce dossier là à ce
jour mais ça a pris plus de trois ans
avant même de s'entendre sur qui ferait
la copie du matériel saisi dans ce
dossier là ce qui était fondamental en
fait c'est qu'il y a un débat devant les
tribunaux pour déterminer l'indépendance
des gens qui exécutaient la perquisition
informatique il y a eu un débat
judiciaire qui a duré des années pour
déterminer finalement que cet expert
judiciaire là bien qu'il relève d'un
service de police était indépendant de
l'unité d'enquête une fois qu'on
s'entend là-dessus entre le processus de
déterminer si un privilège
les documents qu'on veut regarder donc
c'est couvert par le secret
professionnel l'avocat voilà après ça
c'est une deuxième étape qui s'ajoute
aux trois ans dans ce cas de figure là
tout à fait ce qui fait que on se
retrouve avec des dossiers dans lesquels
on est des années à devoir patienter
entre le moment de la perquisition et le
moment où les enquêteurs peuvent
commencer à regarder du matériel qui a
été donc
validé par un ami de la cour des amis de
la cour il y a encore pas les rues là ça
prend des gens qui sont disponibles dans
certains cas c'est beaucoup plus long
trouver quelqu'un parce que les parties
peuvent s'entendent sur qui sera l'ami
de la cour qui peuvent se scanner
longtemps sur telle personne telle
personne ça peut arriver ça fait partie
entre autres des délais une enquête pas
juste de faire une perquisition puis
d'analyser des documents évidemment la
perquisition va nous permettre de cibler
peut-être des témoins des gens impliqués
dans le crime dans ce stratagème mais on
peut pas le faire parce qu'on a pas
accès au document initiaux vous menez
une enquête sur des allégations de
corruption autour de la ville de Chambly
sur 3 millions de documents que vous
avez saisi il y en avait un seul qui
était couvert par le secret
professionnel
quels constat vous faites devant un
exemple comme celui-là c'est beaucoup
trop long pour en arriver à un résultat
comme celui-là avez-vous l'impression
que c'est parfois soulever de manière
abusée ce privilège de l'avocat moi
impression c'est que ça peut laisser des
fois
un petit côté cynique de ma part de la
part de mes équipiers justement qui font
les enquêtes en disant bon encore une
fois on va soulever le privilège puis
ils savent qu'on ça va comme briser le
momentum en tant quête parce que ça va
être quoi la conséquence c'est ça
demeure dans l'état actuel des choses
on va frapper un mur tout un travail qui
a été fait pendant des années sera
jamais dévoilé devant un tribunal parce
qu'on s'est enfergé dans des techniques
qualités c'est ça la réalité actuelle
puis ça c'est un sentiment qui est
partagé moi je l'entends de la part de
mes troupes je l'entends aussi la part
de deux organisations policières
maintenant il faut bien s'en rendre
compte là on va frapper un mur parce que
est-ce que la vérité c'est pas que si
tenté qu'on a les moyens de se payer un
bon avocat il y a toutes sortes de
méthodes de recettes qu'on peut déposer
pour faire dérailler vos enquêtes si on
est riche
c'est sûr qu'il y a une question
fondamentale là-dedans à savoir est-ce
que deux justices de justice pour les
gens normaux une justice pour les riches
moi je veux dire je me prononcerai pas
là-dessus par contre une réalité
effectivement c'est que quand les moyens
états du temps tu peux essayer beaucoup
de recours à la cour on le constaté dans
certains dossiers nous et
n'empêche que
il faut composer avec cette réalité là
c'est ça notre système de justice au
Canada il faut être extrêmement patient
quand on veut faire virer le bateau de
la justice il faut donner un coup de
bord à nous méthodes
la gestion de ces requêtes-là devant les
tribunaux le privilèges de la
conversation est un avocat ils sont
clients pour moi c'est fondamental je
veux pas remettre ça en question mais on
peut dessus évoluer puis moi là je pense
qu'on est rendu là avez-vous quand même
une certaine impression que vous êtes
plus au sommet des priorités disons j'en
suis très conscient par contre je peux
vous dire une chose le jour où il y a un
scandale de corruption qui ressort
demain matin on est prêt à agir c'est
fondamental d'avoir une société
démocratique comme la nôtre puis pour
s'assurer que nos institutions que les
gens qui sont titulaires de ces charges
soit des gens qui soient dignes de nous
représenter donc il y a pas de tolérance
à des actes corruption c'est pour ça
qu'on est là de sonner l'alerte
aujourd'hui au fond oui absolument les
articles qui concernent la corruption
donc ont été rédigés en 1892 aujourd'hui
on est ailleurs ça a évolué les
stratagèmes ont beaucoup beaucoup évolué
donc on se doit d'avoir un Code criminel
qui est actualisé moi j'ai interpelle
les élus au niveau fédéral pour qu'il
nous écoute je pense qu'on a des
solutions également donc écoutez nous
permettez-nous de partager nos enjeux
merci beaucoup monsieur comme ça merci
Madame
[Musique]